the mind is the bouncer of the heart yes
and we're probably over indexed on the
Mind specifically the I don't know if
the left brain right brain dichotomy is
perfect but you know that's sort of what
the left brain represents it feels like
we are over indexed on that or or
there's multiple aspects to us and one
part of us intuitively values the
implicit and maybe the perspectival
participatory procedural like Veri but
then publicly we feel like we have to
Value the propositional the more
explicit
because otherwise that's not scientific
and then we're irrational and we want to
make sure that we're rational and we're
not considered pseudo intellectuals and
so on right so and then we have this
internal Clash because maybe there are
multiple selves and the core of our self
is the one that you know what this feels
right I'm going to go with this but then
we have another self that says no no no
that that's just doubting at one level
the mind is the bouncer but then at
another it's not and we have this
dissonance right